اللقطات محببة ومظلمة ثم
ظهر الهدف،
السفينة الهجومية البرمائية الروسية جورسكي جورنياك على الإنترنت،
طائرة هجومية بدون طيار تقترب من
هدفها، انفجر 450 كيلوجرامًا من مادة تي إن تي
وانقطع البث،
وادعت روسيا أنها صدت هذا
الهجوم، لكن الفيديو يروي قصة مختلفة  لقد
وصل الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني في الأسابيع الأخيرة إلى أبعد وأبعد من
الخطوط الأمامية مما أجبر
الجيش الروسي على نشر دفاعاته البحرية والجوية على بعد
مئات الأميال من
الأراضي التي تسيطر عليها أوكرانيا. كان من
المفترض أن يكون هذا مرسى آمنًا ولم يعد
آمنًا في السابق.  هنا يقول أحد
المدونين العسكريين البارزين ولكن
ذراع كييف أصبحت أطول والمؤخرة
لم تعد موجودة، ويقول إن
حقيقة حدوث مثل هذه الحوادث المؤسفة
واحدة تلو الأخرى ستكون بالتأكيد
شيئًا يجب أن يتحدثوا عنه
اليوم بالنسبة للقيادة السياسية للنظام
الفاشي الروسي.
بالطبع صفعة خطيرة على الوجه،
على الرغم من ذلك، تحافظ روسيا على صورة
كونها مسيطرة، وتقول إن
وزير الدفاع سيرغي شويغو زار القوات في
أوكرانيا المحتلة،
والخريطة التي يشير كلاهما إلى أنها أسوأ بكثير
بالنسبة لموسكو مما تخيلته في أي وقت مضى عندما
غزوا ما يقرب من 18 شهرًا  قبل
نيك بايتون والش سي إن إن zapparesia أوكرانيا